le coc vide créé par fouad et consensus
inattendue face à un marché de l'or noir
fragilisé et inconstant la russie et
l'arabie saoudite ont rappelé ce jeudi à
leurs partenaires la réalité de la
situation
je vous invite une fois de plus à la
prudence et à la vigilance
nous avons contenu les effets de 3 vague
de la pandémie en refusant toute
complaisance
le marché ne s'est pas encore
complètement rétabli bien que nous
soyons maintenant dans une bien
meilleure situation avec un marché en
bien meilleur état qu'il ya quelques
mois à peine
conséquence décision a été prise de
n'augmenter qu'à la marge la production
de pétrole pour le mois prochain un
moyen de garantir une offre plus basse
que la demande et donc de conserver à
prix du baril élevé
il a d'ailleurs retrouvé son niveau
d'avant crise mais dans les faits cette
décision ne s'applique qu'aux autres
membres de l'organisation ainsi
situation compte tenu de la situation
dans laquelle se trouve la russie et le
kazakhstan en termes de consommation
intérieure et de besoins de raffinage
nous avons obtenu l'autorisation
d'avancer le calendrier pour le mois
d'avril
environ 150 milliers de baril par jour
le brésil ghana le reste des membres va
maintenir le gel sur les 350 de gauche
qui si la russie a réussi à tirer son
épingle du jeu
son adversaire présumé au sein de l'opep
en a fait de même
le royaume wahhabite peut continuer à
retirer volontairement un million de
barils supplémentaires par jour et ainsi
conserver son influence sur le cours
mondial du pétrole
finalement les grands perdants de ce
sommet sont les pays les plus dépendants
de la vente d'hydrocarbures comme
l'algérie ou le nigeria s'il souhaitait
à l'origine une hausse des quotas de
production afin de pouvoir augmenter
leurs exportations
ils se sont finalement aligné sur la
position des deux géants choisissant
ainsi la voie de la prudence